Merhabalar
[Alkış]
benim takdim ettiler duydunuz Ben Babür
Erdem
ODTÜ'de doktora öğrencisinin Doktora mı
sürdürüyorum Aynı zamanda araştırmacı
olarak çalışıyorum size Bu sunumunda
arılar üzerinden gideceğim kendi
çalışmalarımız üzerinden gideceğim aynı
zamanda Mühendislik Bilim Teknoloji
nasıl iç içe onu anlatmaya çalışacağım
bunu görmenizi sağlamak istiyorum
Öncelikle şöyle bir giriş yapayım işte
Einstein'ın sözü var denir ya Arılar yok
olacak olursa Nisan en fazla 4 yılı
kalır yalan
bir Einstein böyle bir şey söylememiş 2
Bu sözde yalan
eğer Arılar yok olursa Evet büyük
şekilde doğaya zarar verir ama
Gördüğünüz üzere burada tükettiğimiz
bitkilerin
%35'i hayvanlar tarafından
tozlaştırılıyor ve bu 35'in içerisinde
kelebekler var sinekler var bomba
sarıları var birçok farklı tür var ve bu
türlerin arasında da
içtiğimiz bitkiler değil doğadaki
bitkilerin de yüzde 14'ünü kapsıyor
arıların davranışları üzerine biraz şey
söyleyeyim öğrenme ve hafızaları üzerine
Arılar şekilleri ayırt ediyor sayma
işlemi yapabiliyor zamanı
algılayabiliyor ve kovandan 6 km uzağa
gitseler bile geri bulabilir yollarını
geri bulabiliyorlar ve bilgiye
aktarıyorlar bir arı
bitti bir çiçekten nektar buldu tekrar
kovana döndü ve dans ederek
dişlerini
nerede ölüyor bu nekteri bunu nasıl
söylüyor
şurada yaptığı açı güneşe göre olan açı
ve çiçeğin Uzaklığını da
abdomenini yani ne kadar çok
sallarsa çiçek O kadar uzak demek oluyor
şurada görüyorsunuz sürekli dönüyor yani
bitkiyi aktarıyorlar öğreniyorlar ve biz
araştırmalarımızda arıların öğrenme
becerilerini ölçmek istiyoruz bunu nasıl
yapıyoruz Pablo koşullandırmasını
bilirsiniz işte zili çalar yemek verir
köpeği sonra köpeğin salyaları akmaya
başlar bunu tekrarladığı zaman aralarda
da benzer bir şekilde ölçmeye
çalışıyoruz öğrenme becerisini burada
bir koku veriyoruz aylara herhangi bir
koku tarçın limon çilek fark etmez
ardından başka bir koku veriyoruz
şöyle
koşullandırmak istediğimiz kokuyu
verdiğimiz zaman hemen ardından arıya
Şekerli su veriyoruz Şekerli su
tattırıyoruz ki kokuyla arasında ilişki
tutulsun ve bu sırada dilini çıkartıyor
hortumunu çıkartıyor ve şekeri tadıyor
sonra başka bir koku veriyoruz arıya
yani
hatasız bir koku ve tepki vermiyor
sonra tekrar
koşullandırmış olduğumuz kokuyu
verdiğimiz zaman gördüğünüz şurada arı
tekrar dilini çıkartıyor proboscinsini
çıkartıyor ve bunu genelde bir seferde
öğrenmiyorlar burada tek seferde
öğreniyormuş gibi gördünüz ama birçok
tekrar yapıyoruz Kimisi bazen
bir Suriye arası ve Kafkas bal arısı
görüyorsunuz aralarında bazı morfolojik
farklılıklar var vücutlarında bazı
farklılıklar var Bunlar nedir Burada
şimdi evrimsel biyolojiye giriyoruz bir
adaptasyona giriyoruz burada nedir iri
vücut yapısı var kahkahası yapısının
diğer su değerleri küçük güneşe daha az
maruz kalsın Kafkas Adası kuzeylerde
soğuk enlemlerde yaşıyor vücudu siyah
daha çok Güneş ve diğer bulduğumuz
özellik kafkaslarda yük öğrenme becerisi
yüksek Kafkas aylarında Suriye'de düşük
burada nasıl geçelim olmuş olabilir
şöyle bir şey var Kafkas arılarının bal
toplama
süresi çok az 4 aile sınırlı ve Flora
çok geniş yani 4 ay içerisinde bir
çiçekten bağı toplayacak papatya bitti
papatyalar gelinciklerden bal toplamayı
öğrenmesi lazım
ve
yeterince masa
kışı gelir arıları için böyle bir
sıkıntı yok Neden Hava sıcak kovanlar
açık florasan istediği zaman rahat rahat
toplayabilir ve burada neyi görüyoruz
adaptasyon
öğrenme becerisini de etkileyebiliyor
biri Ayşe Şimdi dedim ya
hibritleştireceğiz bütün konuları bir
araya alacağız burada
tek bilim bilimlerde bilimde
kullandığımız yöntemleri nasıl
teknolojiye aktarırız şimdi dedim ya
istediğimiz kokuya koşullara adapte
edebiliyorsunuz E peki Her TOKİ adapte
edebiliyorsak neden narkotik veya
patlayıcı kokularına adapte Pardon
koşullandırmış olmayalım burada bir
cihaz görüyorsunuz gördüğünüz gibi
Arılar sabit ve dışarıdan aldığı havayı
arıların üzerine veriyor bir insanın
üstünü tarıyoruz hava yağlıyoruz Eğer ki
patlayıcı kokularına koşullandırdıysak
adamın üstünde patlayıcı varsa bu arı
algılar mı sorumuz bu
görüyoruz algılıyor aynı refleks
görebiliyoruz burada Yani bu bilimde
kullandığımız tekniği teknolojiye çok
uzak bir yere aktarabildik
şimdi Mühendislik biyolojiye nasıl
yardım edecek ona geçiyorum burada
görüyorsunuz kraliçe arımız var kovanda
tek üreyen birey ve ona hizmet eden
işçiler var
ve Bu arılar arasında da işçiler
arasında da sosyal etkileşimler var
Nedir bu sosyal etkileşimler Aç olan arı
gidiyor kardeşinden besin istiyor tok
olan arıda kursağındaki nektara
arkadaşına aktarıyor paylaşıyorlar veya
bir kız kardeş diğer kardeşinin üstünü
temizliyor üstünde parazit var mı diye
görüyorsunuz veyahut soğukta
toplanıyorlar birbirlerini istiyorlar
veya kraliçenin etrafında da toplanarak
ne yapıyorlar kraliçeyi korumaya
başlamış oluyorlar
burada bizim deneyimizi görüyorsunuz
burada bir gruba ilaç verdik bir gruba
vermedik ve burada davranışlarını
karşılaştırdık
burada belki gözünüze bir şey
çarpıyordur burada işte daha hareketsiz
toplanma davranışı göstermiş burada daha
hareketli Ama şöyle bir şey var
gözümüzde bir şey gördük ama bunu
sayısallaştırmamız lazım bilimde
yalnızca Ben böyle gördüm oldu diye bir
şey yok bunun sayısallaştırmamız lazım
Bunun için ne yapıyoruz
bu sefer görüntü işleme algoritmaları
devreye ediliyor Bilgisayar Mühendisliği
devreye giriyor arıları takip etmeye
başlıyoruz ve bu şekilde her arının
hızını birbiriyle ne kadar etkileştiğini
çözmüş oluyor sayısal olarak ve bunun
üstüne istatistik analiz yapabiliyoruz
yani bilgisayar mühendisliği ile
biyoloji bir araya geldi bu noktada ve
şunu yapıyoruz aynı zamanda arıların
üstüne barkodlar yapıştırıyoruz ve artık
bu arıların Bir ismi var İşte buna Ayşe
diyebiliyoruz buna Fatma diyebiliyoruz
ve şunu yapacağız şimdi bireyleri
birbiriyle karşılaştıracağız neden bir
bireye daha aktif olabilir Bir birey
daha sosyal olabilir biri daha düşük
işte
hastalığa sahip olabiliyor O yüzden daha
az sosyaldir falan bunları birey
karşılaştırmak istiyoruz Neden şimdi çok
basit bir genel biyoloji bilgisine
gireceğim Ortaokulda bile gösterilir
işte DNA kalıtsal materyalimiz üstünde
gentler var bu genler işte Göz rengimize
boyumuza kan Grubumuzun ne olacağını
belirliyor ve bu genlere isim verelim
agni bgn C geni diye ve böyle daha
küçültelim işte burada yine dna'mız ve
üstünde Ayşe ve Fatma'da kimi Genlerde
farklılık var mutasyonlar var
varyasyonlar var Kimisi birebir aynı ama
Kimisi değil ve Diyoruz ki
farklar varsa bir aktivite farkını
inceliyorsak mesela veya sosyal
etkileşimi inceliyorsa Ayşe daha aktifti
daha pasif davranıyordu daha yavaş
yürüyordu bu Genlerde farklıysa bu
genler neden oluyor olabiliyor Bu bir
olasılık
veya başka ne yapıyoruz
burada Ayrıca İşte bu Aday genleri
belirledik işte ne olduğunu biliyoruz
Artık bu genler bu genler Olabilir ama
burada şöyle de bir şey var şimdi insana
yaklaşacağız tekrar genel biyoloji
moleküler biyoloji evrimsel genetik
devreye giriyor bunu araştırmamız için
ne yapıyoruz ne şunu diyoruz başta
evrimsel diyor Ya ortak bir atadan
geliyoruz Bütün canlılar ortak adadan
geliyorsak genlerimiz ortak gen
ortaklığı var o zaman şuna bakabiliriz
değil mi
farelerde bireyler arasındaki
farklılıkları ölçtük sosyal olarak ve
sosyal olmayan bireyler arasındaki
farklılıkları ölçtük ve dedik ki şu
genler bu farkla sebep oluyor olabilir
buna farede baktık dedik bu genler sahip
oluyor olabilir
ve insanda baktık mesela otizmli bir
insana baktık ve otizmi olmayan bir
insana baktık genlerini karşılaştırdık
bu gende mutasyon var bunda yok otizmli
de bu mutasyon var dedik bunda yok dedik
ve
bu genleri belirledik daha sonra da
Hepsini
birleştirdik bir arada inceledik bu
noktada bioin formatik devreye giriyor
ve bionif analizler sonucunda dedik ki
şu iki gen geriye kaldı
ve bunun sonucunda da diyebiliriz ki bu
otizme aktivite farkına neden olan
genler Bunlar olabilir
ve bakıyoruz Gerçekten böyle bir şey var
mı yoksa Ben atıyor muyum burada
bilimsel araştırmalar yapılmış işte
denilmiş bir tanesinde
beyindeki nöronların aktivitesini
değişimini birbirleri arasındaki
bağlantılarının değişimini etki eden
genleri çıkarmışlar nasıl
bireyleri karşılaştırarak yapmışlar
bunları veya az önce anlattığım şey
insanla Arılar arasında otizmle ilişkili
genler arasında benzerlik görmüşler
böyle bilimsel araştırmalar var tekrar
vermek istediğin mesaja gelirse Siz de
kariyerinizi yönlendirirken artık yeni
bir dünyada izi Arkadaşlar ben
biyolojide okudum biyolog olacağım Ben
bilgisayar mühendisliği okudum sürekli
kodlarla ulaşacağım ben şunu yapacağım
bunu yapacağım bilim yapacak artık durum
değişti Artık oyunun kuralları değişti
Multi disiplor çalışmalar gerekiyor ve
insanların daha genel bilgilere sahip
olması gerekiyor bilimsel çalışma
yapıyorsanız biyolog olacaksınız
bilgisayar kodlama da bilmeniz gerekir
veya böyle bir çalışma yapacaksanız
biyoloji biyologlardan yardım alabiliyor
olmanız gerekir Bu yüzden bu Multi
dislikler adapte olun üniversiteye
başlarken sürekli aklınızın bir
köşesinde olsun
ve şu an bizim çalışma ekibimizi
göstereceğim İşte danışmanım Hande hoca
diğer danışmanı Tuğrul Hoca Ayşegül
Hoca'ya yakın arkadaşlarım Okan Sedat
Oğuz Yavuz bu isimleri Saydım ama bu
isimlerin altındaki kurumlara bakın
bilgisayar mühendisi var biyolog var
beteriner var ve bu şekilde çalışarak bu
araştırmaları yapabiliyoruz
ve tekrar son olarak teşekkür etmediğin
özelliği iki insan var bir tanesi Aykut
Hoca rahmetli diğeri Meral hoca
Türkiye'de bu arı çalışmalarının başını
çeken insanlar aynı zamanda Evrim
ağacının kurulmasını sağlayan insanlar
da Bunlar şu yandaki insanlar da çağrı
ve insan ben biraz yaşlandım bu insanlar
da Evrim ağacının kurulmasını biraz
sağladı diyebiliriz Bu yüzden başta
Aykut Hoca ve mealoca'ya da teşekkür
etmek istiyorum burada
dinlediğiniz için teşekkür ederim
hepinize görüşmek üzere
[Alkış]